DIANA: Hi.
Welcome to Authors at Google.
I am thrilled today to be able
to introduce Mollie Katzen.
I feel like I've
met an old friend.
I have my "Moosewood
Cookbook" from about 1981.
I was in grad school.
And one of my roommates
bought the cookbook,
and we started
cooking out of it.
And I had never been exposed
to vegetarian food before.
And it's absolutely delicious.
And I have made
the quiche recipe
in this book so many
times over the years
I can't even remember.
I can't even count them.
And so I am very, very excited.
And Mollie is here with
her latest cookbook.
How many cookbooks have you--
MOLLIE KATZEN: It's number 12.
DIANA: This is number 12.
My library is a little depleted.
I need to stock
up-- hop on Amazon.
No, I actually talk to Nadine.
That's what I need to do.
"Heart of the Plate"-- and
so please welcome Mollie.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MOLLIE KATZEN: You said you'd
be brief, and you didn't lie.
Thanks for coming.
It's so much fun to be here.
And people eating their lunch
while I'm talking about food
is very homey.
I am thrilled to be here.
I've been enjoying talking
about my 12th and last book.
And I say my 12th and last
book, and then people go, oh.
And then I say don't
worry, because it follows
by four years my
11th and last book.
And I started writing my
last book in 1988 or '89.
But there's a reason for that.
Every time I finish
a cookbook, I
feel that I couldn't possibly
find something more to say.
I feel like how many things
can you say about eggplant?
I've said 42 things
about eggplant.
Maybe there's 48
things to say about it.
But the knowledge
keeps changing,
and the ingredients
keep getting better.
And the demographics and the
willingness and the interest
shifts around quite a bit.
So there's always, it
seems, more to say.
What I want to talk about first
of all, right out of the gate,
since, Diana, you
suggested that this
would be a good portal for
the subject matter at hand,
that the title of this
book and the subtitle
are two things that are worth
looking into because they
were not simple decisions.
The main title of the
book,"The Heart of the Plate,"
doesn't say vegetarian recipes.
It doesn't say how
to not eat meat.
You'll notice it just says
"The Heart of the Plate."
And in fact, it's both a
question and an answer.
The answer is threefold.
Maybe it's four-fold.
But at this point I'm
thinking threefold.
First of all, it reflects
the most literal fact that
to eat a certain way based
on plant foods taking up
most of your plate
is heart healthy.
So there's the heart part of it.
That's your heart.
And then there was
a very personal memo
I got from my editor on this
book who when she launched me
into it when we finished our
discussion outlining what it
might be, she said,
OK, I don't want
to see you or hear
from you for two years.
Write your heart.
Goodbye.
And then I'm sitting there
thinking, write my heart.
What does that mean?
And it evolved into
writing what I love.
So there's that
romantic interpretation
of "Heart of the Plate."
And then there's
also the plate itself
and what is at the
heart of your plate?
What is at the
center of your plate?
And that is where it
becomes a question.
What is the model
that we've grown up,
the model that lets
us know we've eaten?
There are so many
psychological associations
with what it means to
have a plate of food that
satisfies you.
It's not just eating cerebrally,
what I think I should eat,
or eating centrally,
what I'm hungry for.
It's also what you're
hungry for emotionally,
the plate of your childhood,
which for many of us
has a big hunk of
meat at the center.
And if vegetables
appear there, they're
mostly decorative or a
token or on the side--
literally, side dishes.
But the main thing is the hunk
at the center of the plate.
I both question
that in this book
and also offer
different arrangements
for your plate, which we'll
talk about in a minute.
The secondary title is also
a series of semantic queries
and challenges-- "Vegetarian
Recipes for a New Generation."
I use the word vegetarian
pretty much for the first time
on the cover of any of my books.
It's not a word I
like, and for me,
the interpretation of
that word is not simple.
What does vegetarian mean?
I am not somebody who's
against eating meat.
In fact, I like a little
bit of meat once in a while.
And so here I am talking
about a vegetarian book,
and we go right to
the subject of meat.
In fact, for the most part,
if you think about it,
when people talk about
vegetarian-- when someone
sits down at your
table and says,
I'm a vegetarian--
what they're mainly
doing is making a
statement about meat,
as in, I don't want any; as
in, keep it off my plate.
In the 40 years in which
I've been writing cookbooks,
I have found that almost always
the word vegetarian is that.
It's about meat,
as in keep it away.
And also, I have found so many
self-described vegetarians
for whom it has nothing or very
little to do with vegetables.
It's mostly about the meat.
So it's not as
though someone says,
I would like to stop
eating meat and therefore I
am madly interested
in Brussels sprouts.
The stopping eating meat for
whatever reasons, whether it's
ethical or environmental or
some combination or aesthetic,
very often has nothing
to do with whether or not
you're going to be chowing
down on kale salads,
which, by the way,
I think were just
invented in the last two years.
Something happened with kale.
We can explore.
So I use the word
vegetarian in the subtitle,
in the secondary title,
because I personally
choose to redefine it.
My definition of vegetarian
has nothing to do with meat
except for the fact that in
my perfect world, by the time
we're all done putting
as much beautiful plant
food on this reconfigured
plate as we want,
there isn't much room
for anything else.
If there's room, is an
incidental topping, which
could be egg noodles,
which is, in my book,
a thin omelette
sliced into strips
so that it looks like
noodles, but it's really egg.
Same thing with
tofu-- tofu noodles.
If somebody wants a little bit
of meat but mostly vegetables,
it could be a few strips
of last night's steak,
left over, cut on top.
But it's not a statement
about meat, really.
It's a state about what
is the whole plate.
And the plate is
filled with plant food.
So this leads me to my
new vegetarian definition,
which I hope you'll
agree with and adopt,
which is I want vegetarian
to become in our vernacular
an adjective that describes
the food on the plate
and not a noun that identifies
the person eating the food.
Can we all repeat this?
Repeat after me.
Once we do that, once we
take the word vegetarian
and describe the
food with it instead
of IDing the person with it,
it becomes incredibly flexible.
And it becomes, I
hope, a big tent
where everybody feels like they
can sit down at the same table
and eat the same basic meal.
Whether they're adding
that little bit of strips
of steak on top or the little
bit of egg on top or not,
this is a table where somebody
who was a strict vegan--
meaning, as you all probably
know, no animal products
whatsoever, no
egg, in some cases
no honey, nothing that has
anything to do with animals
except for the problematic fact
that soil, good healthy soil,
is filled with little tiny
microorganisms that are alive.
Little inconvenient fact, but
other than that, it's basically
is completely
independent of animals--
the vegan can sit down at the
table with the vegetarian who
eats lacto-ovo, as
they say, with somebody
who might have had steak
for dinner last night
and might have it
again tomorrow night
but tonight wants
the plant food.
They can all share
the same meal.
And it's a big
tent, one big table,
everybody enjoying their
plant food together.
That's my dream
situation-- very long way
of saying that's
basically the beginning
part of my secondary
title in the book.
But I'm not finished
yet with the title
because the secondary part
of the secondary title
is "Vegetarian Recipes
for a New Generation."
I had somebody my age
say to me, oh, but I
want to cook from it, too.
Is only for the young people?
And I said, oh no, that's not
what I meant by generation,
or is it?
Then I realized, oh,
multiple meanings once again.
New generation-- yes,
people coming up, learning
how to cook, young
people who, in my life,
the young people have a far
more open hearted, embracing,
ecumenical sense
of what food is.
It's much less narrow
than when I was coming up.
At least those are the
young people I know.
But also, the new generation
part first personally to myself
because I grew so much
as a cook from the time
I first published "The
Moosewood Cookbook"
until publishing "The
Heart of the Plate"--
almost 40 years in between.
I became a much better cook
and a much simpler cook.
My cooking used to be very
complicated, at least to me.
When I first started,
once upon a time,
I considered it very clever to
put as many things in any given
dishes as you could
find in your kitchen.
I call it the kitchen
sink school of cuisine.
And so I would be breathlessly
going through my kitchen
and dumping everything I
could into a single dish,
always with sunflower
seeds and soy sauce.
And if eggs went in,
they'd be beaten,
so it would hold together
and come out hopefully
in squares or triangles or
whatever shape you want.
But it was a very complex,
layered sense of cuisine,
if that's what you can
generously call it.
But now, I will keep
it's so simple this
if just a splash
of good olive oil
will make something
taste good to maybe
a sprinkle of some designer
salt, I'm thrilled.
The old days, I thought
it meant you were clever
if you could put a lot
of stuff in a dish.
Nowadays, I don't
feel like it's really
about people thinking the
cookbook author is clever
so much as I really
want people to get
their dinner on the table.
And I am your
coach, and I really
want you to be cooking at home,
except for the fact that they
feed you so well here.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLIE KATZEN: I was having
lunch here, and I was asking,
is it OK to talk about
cooking at home to people
who work at Google and get
all their meals-- it is?
I like the nod.
Thank you very much.
And then there's one more
piece to the definition
of new generation,
and that is it's
romantic-- bear with-- the idea
of regeneration in all of us,
that we can all learn new
skills and be opened up.
Even though we're
very experienced,
we could be opened up to
new experiences and new ways
of looking at cooking and food.
If I have two goals-- and
I like to narrow it down.
OK, three-- neither
one of them has
to do with getting
people to eat less meat,
although that is
embedded in my message.
One of them is to get people to
fall in love with plant food.
Another one of them is to
get people cooking at home.
Forgive me, Google.
Cooking at home is a wonderful
birthright to all human beings,
cooking where we live,
making our own food.
And that's a skill that needs
rescuing in our culture.
So I'm part of that squad.
And then the third goal
is-- and this is perfect
because you're divided it
into two sets of chairs,
so you can be the visual--
we have in our culture
a sense of dichotomy about food.
So here's the
firewall, this aisle.
And on one side is food that's
healthy and good for us,
that we know we're
supposed to be eating.
And it's very depressed, and
it's not very well seasoned.
It's those spears of raw
broccoli and zucchini from 1982
when you go to a
cocktail party--
big ones, really raw, like never
cooked ever, with an onion dip.
And everyone's standing
around, thinking,
ew, pretending they like it.
But if it's the undercooked,
under-seasoned, under-salted--
I call it remorse cuisine.
It's healthy.
And you will be
miserable eating it,
but the paradox is you'll
live supposedly longer.
But you won't really want to.
Life will be longer, but
it will seem interminable.
But the dichotomy
on the other side
is food that's delicious
and sensual and compelling.
And we want it, and we love it.
But we'll pay later
because it will
be unhealthy or bad for us.
And the adjectives that
food writers-- not me--
use a lot for this is
decadent or sinful.
You've seen those in the
restaurants-- or syndrome
where the waiter brings one
piece of chocolate cake for six
of us with six forks,
and everyone's going,
we're being so evil.
But we're going to
really enjoy this,
but we're going to
feel-- the syndrome is,
if it's really,
really delicious,
it can't possibly be healthy.
So we straddle this division,
and we struggle with it.
But long way of saying one
of my very biggest goals
is to get rid of that division
altogether-- no firewall.
Move all your chairs in.
No aisle, except for fire
safety in this building,
and understand that food
that is good for you
and food that is delicious
can be a one and the same.
Good for you, good
tasting, just get
rid of all of the other words
and just use the word good,
and all the food
can be delicious.
And that's one of my goals.
One of the things that's
made it so much easier
to write vegetarian/plant
food-based cuisine
is that ingredients have
gotten so much better.
Putting this into a cultural
and historical context,
40 years ago, when I
started writing cookbooks,
you could not find a bottle
of really good olive oil
in this country in
any supermarket.
You could barely find
fresh vegetables.
Bell peppers, for example,
were always green and bitter.
Red bell peppers did
exist, but they were rare,
and they were expensive.
If you found one,
it was a big deal,
and you would have
to call somebody
when you found a
good red pepper,
and you'd want to use it
judiciously and not waste it.
Things we're so much
more limited then.
And also-- and this
is a mixed blessing
because I'm nostalgic
for this-- the fact
that food really was local
and seasonal because that
was all you could get.
Until very recently, it
wasn't a thing to be local
or to be seasonal, which
now it's become chic.
But it used to be
what there was.
Local food was the
food that grew near you
that you would get in season.
I'm from upstate
New York originally.
I now live in the
East Bay, which
is so heavenly in
terms of fresh--
my East Coast friends
are so envious
because I just put
in a bed of lettuce,
and it's beginning of December.
We're very blessed to live here.
When I first moved to the
Bay Area, the very first time
in the early '70s, when
I was writing recipes,
I would have to call my mother,
who lived in upstate New York,
in the middle of winter to
see what was available there.
And practically nothing was.
I didn't want to
write recipes only
for people who lived
in the Bay Area,
although that would've
been a whole lot easier.
So the idea that we can
get most food most places
most of the time is a
very mixed blessing.
But the good side of it is it
makes it a lot more possible
to write recipes that are
very simple for very good
produce a good deal of the time.
There are grains and legumes and
different kinds of nuts and not
just good olive oil but
all sorts of good oils.
Oils made from roasted nuts
are some of my favorites,
that you can drizzle on
at the end of your cooking
and have it taste
just berserkly good.
I love that you're smiling.
You've done that, haven't you?
I can tell.
So all this good
selection of ingredients
makes it so easy to cook simply.
My idea now of a really
good plant food dinner
is several different
smaller things
on the plate in some kind
of a smaller arrangement,
rather than throwing
everything all together.
What you'll find a lot in
The Heart of the Plate.
is a simple legume dish
next to a simple grain dish.
I call it a pilaf, although
technically it's not.
But just a little bit
of a cooked grain,
maybe mixed with
another cooked grain,
a drizzle of that nut oil,
a matching nut, toasted,
sprinkled on top-- done.
Maybe a little
parsley-- maybe not.
That next to a simple-
again, olive oil,
it's my cooking crutch.
People ask me how my
cooking has changed.
How do I characterize it?
I say, two words-- olive oil.
There might be a
mashed vegetable.
I'm so in love with
mashed vegetables.
I think I'm still
reacting to those spears
of the raw broccoli
from 30 years ago.
So I've gone the
other direction,
and now I cook it
until it's really soft
and run it through
the food processor,
thinking if mashed potatoes,
why not mashed broccoli?
I have mashed parsnip.
I just recently
discovered celery root.
It looks really gnarly
and unapproachable.
But if you approach it,
it's like that big dog
that looks from a distance
like there is a big dog.
And you go up close, and
it's wagging its tail.
Not a good metaphor
for a vegetable,
but it's friendly in
that way and sweet.
And you peel it easily and
cook it up and mash it.
But on top of the
mashed vegetable,
you can put a grilled
vegetable that
has crisp, caramelized edges
and play with the textures.
You can garnish things
with nuts and fruit.
You can make the
plate beautiful.
Guess what we just
completely circumvented?
We circumvented the
hunk of something
at the center of the
plate, because this
is more of a collaboration.
Rather than everything
going into one dish
with the sunflower seeds
coming out and the squares,
I've got a variety.
I love all the metaphors--
the collaboration.
The plate looks like
a mandala, or maybe it
looks like a constellation.
Or maybe it's a Bento box.
When I do cooking with
preschoolers in Berkeley
they say, it looks
like a peace sign.
And when I do cooking classes
with the kids in Moran
they say, it looks like
a Mercedes Benz logo.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLIE KATZEN: It's so
similar with the arrangement.
I was showing this
to one of my siblings
who grew up with me
in the late 1950s,
and so he said, oh,
it looks like the TV
dinner with the
little sections--
however you want to
see the metaphor.
But it is a plate
that's playful.
It's a plate that's fresh.
It isn't necessarily
at all more work,
because every little component
on the dish is really simple.
And it becomes a symphony.
It becomes, as I
said, a collaboration,
and it's really a lot of fun.
And I enjoy it greatly.
You could also, though,
go the other direction
and-- I hate the stealth
approach to vegetables,
but in fact, this
is-- you can start
to creep more vegetables
into the dishes.
The comfort food
classics that you
might love like mac
and cheese or lasagna
or even just plain cooked rice,
start mixing some vegetables in
to spruce it up and color it up.
At a certain point, we get what
I call the food flip, which
is that where you started
maybe with, oh, I don't know,
vegetable fried rice and
you added so much vegetable
matter to the rice
that it started
to favor the vegetables
you cross over,
and it becomes rice fried
vegetables because you flipped
it in favor of the vegetables.
Or with layered lasagnas,
seasonal lasagnas--
we're in late fall
now, so I have
four of them, one
for each season,
plus one with just every kind of
mushroom you can possibly find,
a lasagna overwhelmed
with mushrooms
that nobody will
ever complain about.
At this time of year, it's
roasted butternut squash,
layered with the noodles but the
squash outnumbers the noodles.
So if people are saying they
don't want to eat carbs,
so you don't have to.
The vegetables have the
glycemically perfect carbs.
And there are roasted red
onions, and there's ruby chard.
And it's a lasagna.
It is so much fun to do this.
And I just want to say also
in terms of food fads and food
styles and what's trendy-- and
I'm often asked what's trendy,
and I say I have no idea.
Would you like to just know
what I just ate for lunch?
Because that's my current
trend-- one of the things
I'm so grateful for is
the end of certain trends.
I date some of them mostly
to, say back, again,
the early '80s with those
raw broccoli spears.
The Ten Speed Press edition
of "The Moosewood Cookbook,"
which is the one that most
people know, came out in 1977.
Just a few years later, in
the early '80s, in addition to
the raw vegetable fad,
suddenly everybody
was talking about low fat
being the ideal way to eat.
And I don't know
how this happened,
but the low fat craze
set in in the early '80s.
And suddenly, everything
had to be steamed.
It was part of, again,
the remorse cuisine.
And I just have to
share how painful it
was for this
cookbook author to be
trying to come up with a
recipe for potato latkes
during the low fat era.
It was really depressed.
It was so sad.
And there was just no way
you could make polite latkes.
They have to be really
rudely oily and crisp.
Interestingly, if you were
to graph the low fat trend
in the '80s, the obesity
epidemic mirrors it exactly.
And those were the
days when I would
make a beautiful chocolate chip
cookie filled with real butter
and offer it to somebody.
And they would say, oh no, I
cannot eat that because it has
butter in it.
And then they'd go to the
store and buy an entire boxes
Nabisco Snackwell's
fat free cookies
and eat the entire
box of cookies.
This was the most irrational--
thank you for going like this.
You guys are so good.
When that fad finally
subsided-- of course,
it morphed into the low carb
fad, the Atkins one-- what
all of that subsided,
what we were left with
was just real food.
There is nothing more
satisfying to me now
than to, again, that
bottle of olive oil
and being able to drizzle
it on the vegetables
and knowing it is one of
the healthiest things you
could possibly do.
This is such a
great piece of news.
It's a two-fer or
maybe a three-fer.
Not only does that olive oil
make the food taste better
and make the cook a
whole lot happier.
It also elevates
the bioavailability
of the beta carotenes and
all of the phytonutrients
in that green vegetable.
So you're actually getting more
out of it, you should know,
by adding oil to the vegetable.
So that part is all wonderful.
So in fact, in this
book, because olive oil
is, A, so available now and
so delicious and so high end
and really affordable
when you think
about it in context of
the fact that you will now
be eating a lot
less meat-- again,
this is not against meat.
But certainly when
you eat less of it,
you have more money for the
olive oil and the nut oils--
that cooking becomes simpler,
and it becomes more joyful.
And what happens also is
it becomes more creative.
One of the things I hope people
will do with these recipes
is gain the confidence
to follow them maybe once
and then to just
decide-- and this
is what I tell you in the
beginning of the book.
It's my book until you buy it.
Take it home, and
then it's your book.
They're my recipes
while I'm testing them,
and I'm responsible
for them working.
Take them literally just
once, and then change them
and make them your own.
They're all very, very flexible.
I've tried to keep
them really simple.
I know, for example, that if a
recipe has too many ingredients
in it, if that list,
ingredient list in bold,
if it's one or two ingredients
too long, that you will likely
turn the page and not make it.
So I've tried to keep it
as simple as possible.
And in cases where there are
a lot of things that you could
add-- because they
were on my list
when I went into my kitchen
to test this recipe,
I thought I might
end up adding x, y,
and z in addition to a, b, c, d.
But I didn't get to x, y,
and z because at d or e,
I took a taste, and I was happy.
And there was a
part of me going,
I'd like to add all these other
ingredients because it makes
me look more clever, and it
makes the book look cooler.
Then I thought there's
somebody at home who's
had whatever kind
of day they've had.
They have whatever kind
of time constraint.
They're in whatever
kind of mood,
and they need to get
dinner on the table.
I'm really thinking about you.
And I want them to, at
a glance, have a sense
that this recipe is
something that they can do,
and so I keep it simple.
However, the part
of my list that
didn't make it into the basic
recipe is on the next page
under a heading called
optional enhancements.
And that's where I get to
share what I might have done
or what you might do to
take it further and make
it more complicated.
But in the meantime, I've kept
it as simple as I possibly can
and as friendly
as I possibly can.
And so I hope this will
find you making friends
with more vegetables, more
grains, more legumes, more
nuts, cooking all together,
and feeding people and making
them happy.
I also really hope that when
you sit down with people--
and this is another
one of the reasons
I question the word vegetarian.
When you make this
beautiful plant food,
I hope that people
sitting down at the table
together who have different
eating identities--
say there's vegan, a
self-identified vegan,
because I hate
the labels myself.
I really don't
like them, somebody
who identifies as a vegan
and somebody who identifies
as a vegetarian and
somebody who has no clue
and is just there for the food--
that for at least the duration
of the meal, we leave all
these differences behind
and that nobody judges
anybody else's mouthful
and that everybody eats
peacefully at the table,
because the last
thing I want to do
with the vegetarian
and the vegan
and all these
different identities
is add to the sense of
otherizing other people
over personal choices
and habits through food.
Food-- and this is the
preachy part of my talk,
I'll keep brief--
it should be the one
thing that brings us together.
The table should
be the place where
whatever other divisions we
feel, disagreements we feel,
or the otherization
of others that we feel
can be left at the
door and for once,
just for the
duration of the meal,
we can sit down and not feel
as differences but chow down
together and enjoy
the same food,
even if the person next to
puts that little leftover
steak on top of their broccoli.
So that's my hope for all of you
and how you'll use this book.
And now I open the floor
to your many questions,
which I'm sure you'll have.
AUDIENCE: What's your
favorite brand of olive oil
to keep around for
a general cooking?
Because there are so many--
at the supermarket even,
there are so many.
MOLLIE KATZEN: I know,
there are so many brands.
Another benefit to
living in California
is that the olive oil options
are greater here because there
are so many boutique ones.
I always look for dark bottles.
Olive oil, similar to coffee, is
sensitive to light, heat, air.
If you shop at Trader
Joe's, the best one
there is, in my opinion, the
Greek Kalamata olive oil.
It's the most flavorful.
And then I buy
boutique olive oils.
Or I actually get them sent
to me a lot for tasting.
And the really, really fruity
ones, the highest end ones,
are great for finishing,
not necessarily for cooking.
The smoke point for olive
oil is pretty resistant,
but those really fruity ones--
but I'd say my workhorse one is
that Kalamata one
from Trader Joe's.
I use olive oil for
most things, but when
I'm not using olive oil,
my other workhorse oil
is grapeseed,
which I love a lot.
Just the green color
is so beautiful.
DIANA: [INAUDIBLE]
cookbook, how is it new?
MOLLIE KATZEN: It's new because
the publisher wanted the word
new on there.
AUDIENCE: There are
some differences.
I compared it to my old
one-- but not a lot.
MOLLIE KATZEN: There
are some differences.
And this is all going to change
because in the fall of 2014,
we're going to reissue The
Moosewood Cookbook for one
of its many anniversaries.
This will be the 40th of my
own self-published edition.
And we're going to combine some
of the old and new material.
In 1992, when "Moosewood"
was about 15-- because again,
there were many editions--
I went through the book
and tested every recipe again.
I wanted to see if I
agreed with myself.
I wanted to see how I would cook
those recipes 15 years after
and hadn't been at the Moosewood
Restaurant for a long time
and just wanted to see.
I'd never made
them all in a row.
I really actually
went chronologically
through the book, and I
would glance at their recipes
and then close the book and
then improvise and write down
what I did and compare.
And in many cases,
it was identical.
And in some cases,
it was not, because I
had a lot of extra
butter and eggs
that I purposely put
into the early recipes
that I felt could come not
necessarily completely out
but could be reduced.
So there are recipes, for
example, the French onion soup,
which I believe in
the original one
had eight tablespoons of
butter for about six to eight
servings, and I
realized that it could
taste just as good with only
maybe three or four or two
tablespoons of butter.
So it was trimmed
down in that way.
And then I added
some new recipes.
I took out some recipes I
thought no one ever used,
but then some
people yelled at me
because they had
actually used them.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I have a
couple of questions.
First of all, it's such
a treat to have you here.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I recently
moved to Berkeley,
and so it's fun to know
that you live there.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Monterey market?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So my first question
is if you could
talk about protein-rich
vegetables or the protein
content in vegetables.
And then the second thing, I am
having a chef over for dinner,
and I'm not as good
of a cook as he is.
And I'm wondering if
there is any recipe
that you particularly recommend
from your new cookbook?
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLIE KATZEN: Oh, boy.
What kind of chef--
any specialty?
Nice person?
I assume it's a nice
person if you're
inviting this person for dinner.
AUDIENCE: Very nice,
open person, yeah.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Well, I'll
start with the second one
because it's easier for me to
answer the second question.
I would guess, wild guess,
just out of the blue,
most cooking
professionals never get
invited over to anyone's
house for dinner
or rarely do and will
be grateful for anything
you serve.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLIE KATZEN: Just a
little trade secret.
Keep it very simple.
Keep the ingredients
really fresh.
This is pure, simple arithmetic.
If x tastes delicious and
y tastes delicious and z
tastes delicious and it's
not a crazy combination
but it's logical, they're going
to taste delicious together.
They're not going to lose
traits as they blend.
It'll build.
Unless it's wild and crazy,
in which case, good luck.
See, it might go well.
But I would say keep
it really simple
and make sure the ingredients
are top of the line.
And then I love my mac
and cheese recipes.
One of my favorites is the one
that has spinach and mushrooms,
and the white sauce, which
is made with white cheddar,
is also made with beer.
That's one of my
favorites, personally.
And then you can top it
with toasted walnuts, which
take it over into beyond land.
I do not really know about the
protein levels in vegetables.
So I wish I could answer
that, but I don't.
I'm fortunate enough to
have a bit of a pipeline
to the researchers at the
Harvard School of Public Health
Nutrition Department because
they're my good friends.
And they usually keep me
informed about the latest
nutritional findings.
I just owe them--
we all owe them--
so much because they redeemed
oil and fat so beautifully.
Thank you.
But I don't really understand
the protein content
of vegetables so much.
I'm old fashioned in
that I recognize it
more in legumes and
whole grains and nuts.
So I would love it if you find
that if you'd let me know.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So growing up Chinese,
we eat rice with every meal.
So I've started to
substitute the carb part
with sweet potatoes or potatoes.
But beans and legumes and
lentils are my downfall.
I don't know what
to do with them.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Why are
they your downfall?
AUDIENCE: I just don't
know what to do with them.
I didn't grow up with them.
I just boil them and add
salt, and that seems terrible.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Why?
What kind of beans and
legumes are you talking about?
AUDIENCE: Just red
beans, black beans.
So I was wondering if
you had any advice.
I wanted to try different
carbs with dinner
that's not rice and potatoes.
MOLLIE KATZEN:
Well first of all,
for beans, the kind that you
buy dried and soak and then cook
after you soak
them, they do age.
So beans that have been
sitting in some bin,
whether in the store or in your
house, for two years or more,
they will be tougher
and have less flavor.
So even with dried beans, make
sure they're relatively fresh.
Same with dried
herbs and spices,
too-- they sit around,
they all start to smell
like white noise, if
white noise has a smell.
So fresh dried and then soak.
And then lose the soaking
water and cook in fresh water.
What I almost always do
is I'll infuse that water
as the beans are cooking.
Garlic cloves-- whole garlic
cloves go in, chunks of onion.
I'm very fond of adding ginger,
just big slices of ginger.
If you can get fresh turmeric,
things like that-- seasonings
directly in.
Sometimes when I'm
going Italian style
with white beans,
one sprig of Rosemary
in with the garlic in
the bean cooking water,
they will infuse utterly.
They'll soak it
right up, and they'll
retain that flavor-- and
then a good, fruity olive oil
if it's Italian style.
If it is Asian style-- a nut
oil or a roasted seed oil,
sesame or pumpkin seed oil.
Those oils, they're volatile.
They're precious in every way.
They're precious
in terms of being
a little pricey and,
again, unstable.
But you keep them
in the refrigerator
and use them sparingly
as a finishing.
And that can help a lot, too.
But you wanted to go
beyond beans-- tofu,
make tofu taste better?
I almost always, no matter how
firm the tofu is to begin with,
I simmer it in water
before I do anything.
I have a water first, oil
second, begin with water,
finish with oil manifesto.
If I could summarize
in general cooking,
for example to
blanch vegetables,
it's a wonderful
way to handle what
I call the vegetable
volume challenge.
You get home from
the farmer's market
or wherever you
bought your produce.
And you're very well
meaning and bushy tailed,
and you want to get five
a day or, actually, it's
more like 9 to 11 a day
now of vegetable servings.
If you're serving
a family of four
and you only can get to the
grocery store or the produce
market once a week,
you have to come home
with 120 servings
worth of vegetables.
And it's all well and
good, but they're huge.
And they don't fit anywhere.
They're going to go bad.
So you get your
favorite big pot.
By big, I'm favoring
wide over tall.
Get some water simmering
and blanch everything.
Give everything 10, 20,
30 seconds in the water.
You don't even have to cut it.
You could hold chard
or kale by the step
and just hold it
in, count to 10,
take it out, ring out
the water, let it cool.
Blanching vegetables
ahead of time will,
once they're cool and
drained, their shelf space
will be cut by more than half.
Their shelf life will
be more than doubled.
So they will last
the week, and they
will take up a whole
lot less space.
And the third wonderful
thing about doing this
is that you've now created
instant vegetables for later
in the week because their
shelf life has been so extended
that all they need--
and here it comes again,
the olive oil-- just a quick
ride through some olive oil,
maybe with some garlic.
And they're an instant
vegetable for dinner.
So that's nice.
With tofu, I like to also
blanch it 10 minutes.
It firms up so beautifully.
Then part two,
oil-- part two oil
with the vegetables, part
two oil with the tofu.
Then you can fry
it up more crisply.
Don't be afraid of high
heat, depending on your oil.
Spectrum Organics-- I believe
it's spectrumorganics.com--
is a website that charts
the different smoke
points of different
oils and how high you
can take them temperature-wise
with keeping them stable.
So it's a good frying
guide, because if frying
is done with the right oil
and the right temperature,
it can be very clean, and it
doesn't end up being greasy.
So tofu that has
been simmered first
or tempeh, which is an
inoculated soy product,
fermented, then they
go into the hot oil,
and you get them really crisp.
And then you have the whole
texture thing going on.
And then that should
do it for you, I hope.
But using oil in the right
way makes a huge difference
and using heat in the right way.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question regarding
your favorite olive oil.
There's been conflicting
information around it.
And the title of your book
has the word heart in it.
One of the heart
experts, Dr. Esselstyn,
he's been advocate
of not using oils.
So I was wondering if you
have any insights around that,
especially given your pipeline
into Harvard Nutrition?
MOLLIE KATZEN: You mean
about a low oil diet?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
In fact, there are people
who say no oil diet.
But olive oil, a
lot of that, do you
have any insights as to whether
there is good research about--?
MOLLIE KATZEN: I
have to qualify first
by saying I am not a
nutrition researcher nor am
I a dietitian, so I just pilfer
information from those who are.
It's my understanding that
oil is very heart healthy,
that olive oil, that you
should go out of your way
to include it in your diet
because it is, in fact, a heart
protector.
And nuts also-- not even just
nut oils but nuts, avocados,
those kinds of oils are
very, very healthful.
And I believe-- and I
will check with him--
but I am pretty sure that Dr.
Walter Willett of the Harvard
School of Public Health, who
is the head of their nutrition
department, is up to a
good probably 30% or more
of the calories per
day that he would
like you to get from
olive oil alone.
The model is called
The Mediterranean Diet,
and it also includes fatty fish.
It also includes one or two
drinks a day of alcohol.
So for people who like
alcohol, that's a nice thing.
So for the people I know
and the people who school me
in these things, I
would say that I'm
very pro healthy oil
but anti unhealthy oil.
But it's a question of
the quality of the oil.
It's not all fat is bad,
but look for the good oils.
In fact, it really
makes no sense
according to these researchers--
and I am totally convinced
by them-- to, when you
see those labels on food
and they tell you
calories from oil,
percentage oil, grams
of fat-- meaningless.
What does that say?
What do you take home from that?
It's all about quantities of
fat, which don't mean anything.
It's not a different
kind of calorie.
It's not necessarily
bad or good.
You have to look
further and see what
is the actual source of fat.
But it is my understanding
that a good oil
is a very healthful thing.
The expression, the phrase,
essential fatty acids,
the word essential is literal.
Those are fatty acids
that your body needs,
that your body
cannot manufacture.
So you need to take it in.
You need to ingest it.
AUDIENCE: Quick question
on pots and pans
that are used in
cooking-- is there
a difference between, say,
cooking in a non-stick pot
or pan versus an iron
skillet, because I've
been led to believe
that they do make
a difference in the
flavor of the food?
MOLLIE KATZEN: What's
your experience?
What kind of difference
do they make?
AUDIENCE: Well I just wondered.
I don't cook much.
I just hear about it.
And I'm planning to
buy some pots and pans,
so I thought your
feedback would be useful.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Yeah, I do have
an opinion on it, just the way
I feel about cooking and the
way a pot or pan feels to me.
I want it to be as
heavy as possible,
and I go for horizontal
cooking as much as I can.
It's interesting.
I could give a whole other
talk about how my cooking has
changed, and one of the ways
is the shape of my cooking used
to be more vertical, and
now it's more horizontal--
horizontal meaning that
every tidbit in the pan
gets its own place in
the sun, so to speak.
Contact with the surface,
with the heating surface,
is in itself a way of
flavor being imparted
because that cooking
surface, depending
on its proximity to the heat
and the intensity of the heat
and the kind of oil,
is itself a seasoning.
At that point, that's
the point where
you can actually hear the sound.
When you the sizzle of a
tidbit going into the pan,
you hearing the
imparting of flavor.
It's a beautiful thing.
I don't like non-stick
pans because I'm
suspicious of the materials
used in the coating, which
can leach into the food.
And they're chemical,
and they're not
necessarily healthful.
They can, in fact,
be unhealthful.
This isn't completely-- I was
going to say it's not ironclad.
[LAUGHTER]
MOLLIE KATZEN: But it is
pretty much the rule of thumb
is I would avoid coatings.
So I like heavy.
I love cast iron, and it's
also the least expensive.
And for me, it's
the most nostalgia
inducing because the
first cookware I ever
had was cast iron.
And it's a very honest cookware.
And I like the fact you can
heat it really well and slowly.
I'd much rather
have a pan that's
been heated on a medium-low
flame for a longer
period of time than flashing
something with a sudden burst.
So I would go with
something-- anodized
steel is a really nice,
heavy kind of cookware which
I like a lot and
then the cast iron.
But avoid anything
that's very lightweight--
literally lightweight--
and that is coated.
One way you can have a non-stick
situation without it being
officially non-stick
is if you're
patient with the
heating of the pan
and make sure it gets very,
very hot and then add your oil.
And then make sure the
oil itself gets very hot
so that when the food finally
goes in, you hear the sizzle.
Again, hearing the
sizzle tells you
that it's probably
not going to stick.
And then you have
a metal spatula
with which you scrape
the food as it cooks.
And you shake it, keep it
going, to keep it from sticking.
You're the non-stick factor.
Your cooking habit becomes
the non-stick factor.
My recipes used to say, oh,
just cook the vegetable.
It didn't even
say, heat the pan.
I don't even
remember what I said.
But now I very
specifically almost always
have one clear instruction
first, pan on heat.
Wait.
Oil goes in.
Swirl to coat.
Wait.
There's a lot of waiting.
It's like a time
signature in music.
There's a little rest.
And then the food
goes in, and you
hear the sound of it being
infused with flavor and with it
becoming something that's
not going to stick.
Did that help?
AUDIENCE: Absolutely, thank you.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you call it
"Recipes for a New Generation",
and I thinking of
my son who used
to read "Pretend Soup" at
night in bed, picking out
the recipe he wanted to cook
in the morning and who asked,
as soon as he saw that you
had a new cookbook out, said,
this is the book I want,
"The Heart of the Plate,"
in my new apartment.
This is my cookbook
to cook from.
So he grew up thinking
of you as a model,
which I think is wonderful.
And you say this is
your last cookbook.
So what about your last
children's cookbook?
Are you doing more
MOLLIE KATZEN: That's
really possible.
See, I have no
credibility when I
say-- "Pretend Soup"
and "Salad People"
are the two cookbook I
wrote for preschoolers.
There's a reading
readiness embedded,
early, early, early
reading, recognition
of numerals and certain letters.
It was very hard to find
things that preschoolers could
or would do because just
their little arms and things.
For example, everyone
thinks, oh, preschoolers,
we'll make cookies.
Nuh-uh, because they
can't stir cookie dough,
and you don't want to
be doing it for them.
And then I wrote one
later, "Honest Pretzels,"
for older kids, which was
difficult because the level
as is so all over the
map, that some kids have
a lot of experience cooking.
Some don't.
I think there's a lot
more to do with kids,
and there's certainly a need.
And I love hanging out with
kids, so there's a good chance.
Was that the whole
question, darling?
Because she's my friend.
That was it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
another one.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Shall we talk?
Because I love cooking-- kids
are just so fresh and so honest
about food.
And one of the things that's
been so wonderful about cooking
with children is they're so not
what you expect in the kitchen.
I know I'm speaking in a
very broad generalization.
But the idea that they're being
invited in to what is normally
considered an adult realm,
they are so honored.
And we expect them to
want to make a mess.
And what I've found is
when they make a mess,
they get very upset and want
to clean it up right away.
And they really want
to make something
that they can feed you.
And it's a wonderful
way to elevate
a child's feeling
of being effective.
So, OK, I'll do it.
Yay, it'll be fun.
I thought of something I
didn't say earlier that's
an important point for
me, when you asked me
about the materials,
about the pans.
One of the things that
is important for people
who are new to cooking
a lot of vegetables,
really cooking vegetables-- I
grew up with frozen vegetables.
In my mom's house,
it was frozen.
And I actually loved them.
And my first vegetable
dish that I ever cooked
was opening up a package.
And it was green beans.
And most of the
instructions when
I was trying to
write my early recipe
had a lot to do with
opening the package.
First you go to one
end and you open.
You tear it.
And then if it doesn't open,
you take a little knife
and cut it open.
But it was all about getting
it out of the package.
And then you add water
and put it on heat.
And then when the corners fall
off and it's no longer square,
serve.
That was my early one.
But now it's about the knife.
Now it's about, you get
the fresh vegetables home.
And for a lot of
people, I believe
the barrier to cooking
more vegetables
is a little bit of uneasiness
about the knife, which
is a very essential thing.
I call it the knife block.
And again, we talk about
the line in the sand,
before and after.
There is before you
bond with your knife.
And then there is
post-bonding with your knife.
It's a whole different world.
When you find the
knife of your dreams,
it's like finding
a relationship.
And there's no one knife
that's right for everyone.
But there is a knife
that's right for you.
And it feels good in your hand,
and it's got a straight blade.
It can be a 6, 8, 10-inch
blade, but it feels good to you.
And you keep it very,
very, very sharp.
You have it professionally
sharpened once or twice a year.
And it is so exciting
to try to cut something
with a sharp knife
for the first time.
It heads toward an
onion or an apple,
and with almost no pressure
from you, it grabs in.
It's a clean slice.
I'm so into sound
effects, so you
can hear this little whoosh.
And lo and behold, you
have a clean, perfect slice
of onion or apple, and
you then have religion.
And then you've crossed over,
in a good way, to the good side.
And that's when you not only
are willing to cut onions.
You'll cut onions
for all your friends,
and you will look
for things to cut.
When you fall in love
with slicing stuff,
everything changes.
And I just had my
knife sharpened,
so I'm in a really
good mood about this.
It just brightens your life.
You go for the small things.
Enjoy that because
that will really
change your cooking life.
I guarantee it.
AUDIENCE: So always
this time of year,
when there's just that
first chill in the air,
I make that lentil soup of
"The Moosewood Cookbook."
And it warms my heart.
But from your descriptions, it
sounds like you're constantly
jumping from recipe
to recipe, or you're
making a lot of different
things, trying out new things.
How do you balance between
making something new
and going back to old favorites?
MOLLIE KATZEN: That is
such a good question.
I'm wondering why I've never
been asked that before.
You're original.
I test a lot of new
recipes, obviously,
when I'm working on a cookbook.
I'm not always
working on a cookbook.
And in between
cookbook projects--
which take several years
because those recipes, these,
I've tested three,
four, or five times
and actually lose sleep over the
ones I think aren't coming out.
I really care.
When I take off my
making a cookbook hat
and I'm just an
ordinary citizen,
I am pretty much incapable
of following a recipe.
I've tried, and it's hard.
It's a rebellious thing.
I don't know what it is.
And I cook very much
by going to the market
and seeing what's there and what
just speaks to me on that day.
That said, I do have
a few favorites.
I can't really follow
even my own recipes,
but that lentil soup is one that
when I have nothing else going
on, I just automatically
will put lentils on the stove
and start making that.
I cook really simply.
And it's like being on vacation
to not write things down,
because a cookbook is
a technical manual.
It really has to work.
And also, in writing
one, you don't really
know exactly whom
you're writing it for.
What's your habit?
What's you're habit?
What do you need me to tell you?
How comfortable are you filling
in the blanks on your own?
What does your
kitchen look like?
What is your attention span?
What are your taste buds?
I'm guessing.
Not to complain,
but it's really fun
when I'm not having to do
that and when I'm just cooking
and I don't write it down.
On the other hand, if
I don't write it down
and then I really
liked what I made,
I can't remember what I did.
But I pretty much don't cook the
same thing more than once ever
in real life.
I hope that was not
too disappointing,
because it's really true.
DIANA: OK, thank
you so much, Mollie.
That was awesome.
MOLLIE KATZEN: Thanks, Diana.
Thanks for having me.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
MOLLIE KATZEN: So if you'd like
to get your book autographed--